peu à peu les policiers commencent à
élaborer un scénario pour eux tous s'est
déroulé la fameuse nuit où elle
scottomans a été relégué sur le canapé
tandis que S vanderen et Marcel faisait
l'amour dans la pièce à côté
au milieu de la nuit est-ce que Mons ce
serait levé et aurait saboté le
parachute avant de se recoucher
samedi 18 novembre 2006 nous sommes à
opt-clabique une petite ville de
Belgique flamande située à quelques
kilomètres à peine de la frontière
hollandaise
il est midi et demi et comme chaque
samedi Paul a donc une retraité
septuagénaire s'occupe de ces tâches
ménagères
elle vient de pendre son linge dans son
jardin et retournant dans sa maison en
passant le seuil de sa véranda elle
entend un bruit épouvanteur
abasourdi par ce bruit inhabituel qui
semble provenir du ciel Paul a donc se
précipite au fond de son jardin
elle regarde
ivoirien et soudain elle remarque un
drap
un petit peu les buissons et voir un
pied dépassé
[Musique]
une fois
une femme en combinaison sur le dos avec
un filet de sang qui s'échappe de la
lèvre sur la gauche du visage
pour la donte c'est qu'il y a une base
parachutiste à quelques kilomètres de là
cette femme serait-elle tombée du ciel
la retraité prévient aussitôt les
secours
à 12h59 précisément pompiers et
gendarmes belges j'arrive sur les lieux
et leur premier réflexe est de tenter de
réanimer la victime
pratique un massage cardiaque il voit
très vite que qui est très très peu de
chance que que ça puisse que ça puisse
fonctionner que ça puisse marcher
les conclusions sont internes à l'été
protégée par ailleurs par sa son
parachute son arnachement elle offre
envisage qui est décrit comme comme
paisible à ne respire plus à les
manifestement des gens mortes
soudain arrive sur les lieux un homme
qui semble paniquer et qui lui aussi
porte une combinaison de parachutistes
il expliquant aux gendarmes me
semble-t-il que
qui s'appelle Marcel Summers qui les
parachutiste qui connaît la personne
et qui s'est passé quelque chose à la
demande des enquêteurs Marcel Sommers
raconte ce qui s'est passé
[Musique]
ce matin-là Marcel Sommers 46 ans avait
rendez-vous à l'aérodrome voisin avec
trois amis
on a tout un groupe de gens qui qui se
retrouvent qui font partie du même club
de parachutistes amateurs depuis des
années
la bande d'amis est composée de deux
hommes Marcel Sommers et Tom bolcius
[Musique]
il y a aussi deux femmes portant le même
prénom
la jeune elslotomans surnommée Babs 21
ans et elswandown 38 ans il se
connaissent depuis très longtemps ils
ont l'habitude de sauter ensemble ils
sont plusieurs fois par semaine
près de 300 fois par an ce matin-là les
conditions climatiques sont bonnes à
11h50 le feu vert pour décoller et
donner
les quatre amis embarquent alors dans un
petit avion le groupe ne le sait pas
encore mais elswandown va faire une
chute fatal
il décolle et l'ambiance est normale et
bonne
rien de suspect
le pilote fait signe et l'une après
l'autre
quitte l'avion
les parachutistes ont prévu de former
une étoile dans le ciel
Marcel Sommers Tom bolcius et els
vanderen se rejoignent
[Musique]
mais elle slottomans a manqué sa sortie
à quelques secondes près et elle ne
parvient pas à rejoindre le groupe
il est trop tard la figure ne dure que
25 secondes et il est déjà temps de se
séparer et de se préparer à atterrir
Marcel explique aux enquêteurs qui
Louvre son parachute et qu'il a vu deux
de ses camarades en faire autant
en revanche Marcel ne parvient pas à
voir S2 vanderen
et regarde à gauche à droite il ne
comprend pas et puis il s'aperçoit
qu'elle est en fait en dessous de lui
très vite Marcel Summers comprend qu'il
y a un problème
il voit qu'elle est
occupée de d'essayer de d'enclencher son
son parachute ça ne marche pas Marcel
s'inquiète il faudrait maintenant quels
van derun applique la procédure
d'urgence fort heureusement il y a un
système de secours qu'on appelle le
parachute de secours qui est lié à une
deuxième ficelle qu'elle tire et
celui-là est infaillible normalement à
100% Marcel Sommers le sait els vanderen
ne dispose plus que de quelques secondes
pour ouvrir son parachute de secours à
moins de 250 mètres du sol il sera trop
tard problème le deuxième parachute ne
s'ouvre pas non plus
tombe maintenant à plus de 85 mètres par
seconde à cette vitesse elle atteindra
le sol dans moins de 10 secondes
une tombe en chute libre
et bon c'est classe
6 minutes plus tard Marcel Somer
s'atterri il n'a pas vu le lieu de chute
précis de son ami mais il aperçoit une
ambulance sur la route voisine et se
mettent aussitôt à la suivre en courant
[Musique]
s'agit-il d'un accident rien n'est moins
sûr après avoir écouté le récit de
Marcel Sommers pour les policiers belges
plusieurs pistes se dessinent
ils sont donc devant une double
hypothèse une triple hypothèse même soit
en suicide ce qui est possible ça c'est
déjà vu dans le monde du parachutisme
donc le refus d'ouvrir ces deux
parachutes soit en incident technique ou
soit évidemment la thèse du saboteur qui
va très vite apparaître seulement
l'hypothèse de l'accident la première à
laquelle les policiers ont pensé va
sembler peu probable
[Musique]
le responsable du club de parachutisme
d'où s'était lancé le groupe d'amis et
l'un des premiers à émettre des doutes
la possibilité la probabilité que la
femme de s'ouvre pas convenablement
extrêmement rare le système de parachute
sont quand même très très moderne très
efficaces l'ouverture
qui ne se fait pas pour une toile ça ne
se reproduit pas la deuxième fois avec
le parachute de secours
la thèse de l'accident écarté reste
celle d'un suicide ou d'un meurtre
dont le jardin Wells vanderen s'est
écrasé un spécialiste de la base de
parachutisme voisine examine le matériel
à la demande de la police et il constate
vite quelque chose d'anormal
une sangle du parachute a été sectionnée
les enquêteurs pensent avoir affaire à
un sabotage mais le doute subsiste les
sangles ont été coupés or bon dans la
panique est-ce que les secours pour
dégager la victime ont coupé les sangles
bon c'est possible qui a sélectionné les
liens du parachute les pompiers ou un
éventuel meurtrier impossible de le
savoir
et ce n'est pas tout l'expert va
également découvrir que le parachute est
incomplet
on constate que
l'extrateur le petit parachute qui ouvre
le premier parachute n'est pas présent
seront la lieu
et là on commence à se poser des
questions
l'extracteur est une sorte de parachute
miniature sur lequel on tire pour
déployer la voile sans extracteur
impossible d'ouvrir le parachute pour
les enquêteurs l'absence de cette pièce
est suspect
[Musique]
si l'exact ça veut dire que c'est pas un
accident mais que c'est un sabotage donc
notre
durant plusieurs heures une équipe de
policiers ratissent donc les environs
pour retrouver l'extracteur
son succès
tant que cette partie du parachute n'a
pas été retrouvée impossible de
confirmer la thèse de l'assassinat
mais un nouvel élément va peut-être
permettre aux policiers d'éliminer
définitivement la piste du suicide c'est
une vidéo car la mort dels vanderen a
été filmée en intégralité
[Musique]
lors de son seau els vanderen portait
une caméra sur son casque une pratique
courante destinée à améliorer ses sauts
les enquêteurs disposent donc d'une
véritable boîte noire qui pourrait
fournir de précieuses indices
la chute mortelle a été
enregistré filmé de façon presque
subjective la chute de plus de 4000
mètres a fortement endommagé le film
mais après un travail minutieux la bande
peut être visionnée les enquêteurs
découvrent alors des images étonnantes
on voit les moments qui précèdent le
saut on les voit on la voit filmer
Marcel Sommers elle serait Ottomans
tombolcius et les autres parachutistes
présents l'ambiance à l'intérieur de la
karmingue est très très joyeux à 4500
mètres tout le monde s'élance de l'avion
pour effectuer une formation en étoile
à 1500 mètres chacun ouvre son parachute
sauf else vanderen et là on voit
visiblement qu'elle essaie de déclencher
son parachute principal qu'elle n'y
arrive pas donc elle regardant l'air
elle se rend compte qu'il y a quelque
chose qui ne va pas s'agit dans tous les
sens elle tire sur son barrage de rêveur
ce qu'on voit sur la vidéo c'est
vraiment quelqu'un qui se batte pour la
vie qui fait tout qui souffre qui est en
panique
et jure pas elle crie pas elle est
tellement concentrée et soudain c'est
fini
l'image tourne noir
et la morte
a priori les enquêteurs n'apprennent pas
grand chose de nouveau par rapport au
récit de Marcel sommerce mais cet
élément leur permet au moins d'être
certain d'une chose elle se vanderen ne
sait pas donner la mort volontairement
on voit que que fait des efforts
extrêmes pour ouvrir son parachute donc
on peut exclure à ce moment-là
le suicide d'autant que les enquêteurs
apprennent que le matin même à la base
de parachutisme hels vanderen avait
renouvelé son abonnement
ce qui exclut complètement
à 100% le suicide puisqu'elle a raison
d'acheter son nouveau saut si on a prévu
de tout en l'air quelques heures après
désormais pour les enquêteurs la piste
la plus probable et celle du meurtre et
c'est en retrouvant le fameux extracteur
qu'ils vont en acquérir la certitude
21 novembre 2006 trois jours après le
drame en début d'après-midi Marcel
Somers reçoit un coup de fil il s'agit
delse clottomans
elle explique qu'elle s'est perdue
qu'elle connaissait pas bien la route et
que en haut d'un arbre sur son chemin
elle a bu un bout de tissu rouge
ce bout de tissu rouge c'est le fameux
extracteur que les enquêteurs
recherchent depuis trois jours
et très vite les craintes de la police
se confirme
plus de doute possible S vanderen a été
assassiné son parachute sa beauté
mais qui a bien pu en vouloir à cette
mère de deux enfants à la vie bien
rangée mariée à un bijoutier depuis 18
ans
en toute logique c'est vers les amis
parachutistes de la victime que les
enquêteurs vont se tourner car ils en
ont la conviction le sabotage n'a pas pu
être commis par n'importe qui
pour saboter un parachute on doit être
par un justice c'est tout on doit pas un
technicien énorme mais il faut savoir
quel corps doit couper au moins et les
premiers parachutistes que les
inspecteurs vont auditionner ce sont
naturellement les trois membres présents
dans l'avion le jour du drame
[Musique]
Tom bolcius et le premier du groupe de
parachutistes à être auditionné
mais l'instructeur connaissait très peu
s2run et il est très vite mis hors de
cause
en revanche
elsclotomans l'autre femme présente dans
l'avion va se montrer beaucoup plus
bavarde elle va même faire une étonnante
confession au sujet de la victime les
premiers éléments dont disposé les
enquêteurs présentaient elles ont Doron
comme une mère de famille deux enfants
classiques
et là dessus elle est-ce que Thomann
leur explique qu'elle n'est peut-être
pas si lisse que ça qu'elle a une vie
beaucoup plus compliqué beaucoup plus
tumultueuse que ce qu'elle laissait
paraître dans les premiers instants de
l'enquête un peu spontanément elle
expliquait le même aux policiers que
s2o
ne pensait pas que Yann devilde qui est
le mari de elsan Dorn était au courant
de cette relation extra-conjugale
selon else clottomans la victime avait
donc un amant et elle révèle même son
identité il s'agirait de Marcel Sommers
le parachutiste qui avait sauté avec eux
et la jeune femme est encore plus
précise elle affirme que tous les
week-ends
quittait sa famille pour rejoindre
Marcel Sommers
elle quittait la maison soit le samedi
matin soit le vendredi soir jusqu'au
dimanche 23h où elle allait à zouard
Berck pour sauter avec avec ses copains
un parachute
donc elle noircit un peu le sa grande
copine dans
en disant voilà c'est pas une une bonne
femme c'est pas une bonne mère de
famille
le trompe son mari
le même double vie à en croire Babs cela
faisait plus de 5 ans qu'elle vendeuren
et Marcel Sommers entretenait une
relation adultère d'ailleurs au club de
parachutisme tout le monde était au
courant tout le monde est au courant
dans le club c'est notoire se doute même
pas que quel Argentine mari qui l'attend
à la maison à ce moment-là tout le monde
croit surtout dans la jeune génération
tout le monde croit qu'il forme un
couple légitime parce que effectivement
ils se connaissent depuis 2000 ans et
que personne n'a jamais vu avant ça
Marcel avec une autre femme elle
scottomans n'est pas avare de détails
son témoignage va donner un nouveau
tournant à l'affaire
quand est-ce clothman arrive avec cette
information et les enquêteurs ils ont de
beaux suspects sur les bras tout d'un
coup alors que ils avaient pas grand
chose jusque là et là tout d'un coup ils
se disent mais tiens oui il y a d'un
côté Marcel Sommers l'amant est-ce que
il a pas voulu se débarrasser de sa
maîtresse parce qu'elle risque à lui
échapper et dans notre côté il y a le
mari qui aurait pu qu'il y a peut-être
découvrir cette liaison illégitime et
qui ne l'a pas supporté qui a voulu se
venger
l'amant possessif ou le mari jaloux pour
les policiers il est urgent d'entendre
les deux hommes
d'abord les officiers de la police
judiciaire se présentent au domicile de
Yann de Wilde à Rennes une petite ville
résidentielle dans la banlieue d'Anvers
[Musique]
arrivé sur place les inspecteurs
décident de provoquer le mari de la
victime pour analyser sa réaction
les policiers
décident d'adopter une stratégie
qui est un peu celle du poker menteur ou
en fait ils vont distiller de grosses
révélations à Yann Devil pour observer
les réactions du monsieur
tout d'abord les enquêteurs apprennent
au mari la véritable cause de la mort de
son épouse
et lui annonce qu'il ne s'agissait pas
d'un simple accident mais bien d'un
meurtre avec préméditation c'est le
premier choc
oui il est en pleurs il comprend plus
rien il ne croit pas ce qu'il ce qu'il
raconte les policiers
et ça ne s'arrête pas là les policiers
ont une autre révélation à faire au mari
une révélation tout aussi douloureuse
deuxième information capitale
les policiers lui expliquent que sa
femme avait un amant
et observe toujours ses réactions
les enquêteurs ont face à eux un homme
qui est complètement effondré et qui a
l'air de tomber de la lune quand il lui
annonce que qu'en fait sa femme avait en
amont et il a l'air d'être vraiment
vraiment touché et effondré il a pas
l'air de feindre du tout son émotion et
sa son état de son état de choc quoi
Yann de Wild semble effondré mais ce
n'est pas pour autant qu'il va être
innocenté aux yeux des policiers car on
le sait les plus brillants meurtriers
sont aussi les plus manipulateurs
[Musique]
d'autant qu'un élément va jeter le
trouble sur le mari
spontanément l'homme va en effet montrer
aux enquêteurs une lettre anonymes une
lettre reçue par le couple il y a
plusieurs mois sur laquelle on peut lire
pour les policiers Cette lettre fait
clairement allusion à la relation
adultère d'Els vanderen avec Marcel
Summers mais le mari raconte qu'à
l'époque sa femme lui avait donné une
toute autre explication elle lui
explique qu'il y a énormément de
personnes qui ne comprennent pas leur
relation de couple qui ne comprennent
pas le fait qu'elle puisse abandonner
ses enfants son mari tous les weekends
pour aller faire du parachute
pour les policiers cet élément est
capital il prouve en effet que
contrairement à ce qu'il affirme le mari
pouvait avoir des soupçons quant à
l'infidélité de son épouse il disposait
donc d'un mobile solide et ce n'est pas
tout
[Musique]
dans la conversation Yann de Wild
apprend aux enquêteurs qu'il est
lui-même un ancien parachutiste il était
donc parfaitement capable de sa beauté
l'équipement de sa femme d'autant qu'il
y avait facilement accès le parachute de
sa femme else était soit dans son coffre
de voiture à elle soit dans la dans leur
chambre à coucher donc
objectivement il avait des possibilités
d'accéder au parachute aussitôt aux yeux
des policiers Yann the wild passe du
statut de veuf à celui de suspect des
policiers ne partent pas sans lui mettre
une grosse pression
et il lui explique tout bonnement
vous nous dites que vous n'étiez au
courant de rien si par hasard même de
façon anonyme au cours de nos auditions
on apprend qu'effectivement vous étiez
au courant de cette liaison vous ne
voulez pas nous dire que vous étiez au
courant on revient avec les pinces
les policiers emportent la lettre
anonyme pour l'analyser même s'ils n'ont
encore aucune preuve il commence à se
forger une conviction Yann de Wild Marie
trompé aurait parfaitement pu saboter le
parachute de sa femme et la condamner
ainsi à s'écraser lors de son prochain
saut pour les enquêteurs Yann de Wilde
et le suspect numéro 1 mais parrakit
conscience ils veulent tout de même
auditionner l'amant dels 22 run
Marcel Sommer
[Musique]
dimanche 26 novembre 2006
la police judiciaire interroge Marcel
Sommers
son statut d'amant on fait le deuxième
suspect sérieux à leurs yeux
et l'homme va beaucoup les surprendre
non seulement il va confirmer sa
relation avec la victime mais surtout il
va leur faire une incroyable révélation
[Musique]
oui j'avais une liaison amoureuse avec
elles sont Doron
mais j'ai aussi des choses à vous dire
puisque j'ai également eu une liaison
avec elle scottomans
alors là dessus les policiers qui sont
pas au bout de leur surprise découvrent
encore un nouvel élément qui est que sur
les quatre personnes qui ont sauté le
fameux samedi ou moins 3 entretenaient
une liaison amoureuse cependant Marcel
Sommer s'explique aussitôt quel
slottomane n'était qu'une passade
[Musique]
la femme qui l'aime et l'autre celle qui
prend avec qui la des relations
sexuelles parce qu'elles se jette
visiblement à son cou et dans son lit et
quand elle vendo Ron n'est pas làbe
voilà comme c'est un type à moral et il
se pose pas de questions il se pose pas
de problème et qu'en plus c'est là et
qu'elle s'offre il la prend j'étais pas
amoureux d'elle c'est elle qui m'a
dragué tout le temps et bon je suis un
peu tombé dans le piège donc il s'excuse
un peu donc mais donc il explique quand
même temps que son grand amour
était à zono
c'était en deuxième position
pour s'amuser un petit peu et qui
explique aussi qui qui avait pas de
problème avec House clottomans qu'elle
accepte ça être la deuxième elle
scrutement et la victime elle vendeuren
était donc rival et Marcel Sommers va
même plus loin devant les enquêteurs il
accuse la première d'avoir tué la
seconde en fait il leur dit tout Go que
pour lui
que lui il a une suspecte que c'est elle
slottomans
parce que pour lui puisque maintenant
tout le monde est au courant du triangle
amoureux il leur explique très
franchement qu'en fait pour lui elle a
jamais accepté d'être numéro 2
même si en façade laissait cette
impression mais pour lui lui il est
convaincu que de toute façon c'est un
statut qui ne convenait pas du tout pour
accréditer ses accusations Marcel
Sommers va leur raconter un événement
qui s'est déroulé une semaine avant le
meurtre
le vendredi 10 novembre 2006 au soir
Marcel Sommer s'est rentré chez lui avec
elle scottman
c'est une tradition la jeune femme passe
toutes les soirées du vendredi chez son
amant
mais ce soir-là rien ne va se passer
comme prévu
[Musique]
sans crier gare elle entre dans
l'appartement et donc un petit coup de
froid pour battre ce qui croyait que
pour cette nuit-là Marcel serait pour
elle
en entrant dans l'appartement S2
vanderen dépose son parachute dans le
salon
puis se dirige vers la chambre de son
amant pour y passer la nuit
[Musique]
la mante attitré si j'ose dire de
Marseille donc elle se dirige dans la
chambre à coucher de Marseille ils vont
dormir dans le même lit et Babs elle en
est réduite à dormir sur un matelas dans
la salle de séjour bon l'appartement il
est pas très grand il est pas très
insonorisé donc elle assiste sur ce
coucher sur son matelas elle entend les
ébats de des deux amants
cette nuit là elle attend les bruits de
l'amour donc
pendant un certain temps pour ne pas
dire pour pendant toute la nuit elle
subit les gémissements et les cris des
deux amants qui vont passer toute une
partie de la nuit avoir des relations
sexuelles
[Musique]
Marcel raconte que le lendemain matin
tandis quels vanderen et lui donne
encore
else clottomans fait irruption dans la
chambre surexcité
la porte s'ouvre c'est le scottomans qui
rentre et qui a un comportement très
étrange un peu comme une gamine elle se
met assautier dans tous les sens elle
est un peu un petit peu hystérique ils
sont un peu médusés de l'avoir entrée
comme ça dans la chambre ça c'était
jamais produit auparavant et donc elle
s'installe au milieu d'eux dans le lit
et puis elle fait des petites allusions
une partie à trois enfin la scène
vraiment
étrange dure une petite dizaine de
minutes et puis elle sort de la chambre
donc Marcel raconte ça aux enquêtes pour
Marcel Summers cette scène est
extrêmement révélatrice
Marcel explique qu'elle était
frustrée peut-être de ce qui s'était
passé la veille
après l'interrogatoire de Marcel Sommers
les policiers rajoutent elslotomons
alors liste de suspects
[Musique]
presque deux semaines après le drame les
policiers entendent donc à nouveau else
Claude
lors de sa première audition la jeune
femme les avait informés de la double
vie de sa rivale avec Marcel summer
en revanche elle avait caché sa propre
liaison avec lui
[Musique]
fort de cette information les enquêteurs
pensent avoir une longueur d'avance sur
la jeune femme seulement celle-ci ne
manque pas de ressources elle les prend
complètement de cours en leur disant bon
ben maintenant avec tout ce que vous
savez je pense que vous êtes au courant
voilà de ma liaison avec Marcel
alors les policiers sont assez surpris
elle slotomans a-t-elle tué sa
concurrente par jalousie
lorsque les enquêteurs font part à la
jeune femme de leur soupçons celle-ci ni
en bloc pour elle cette liaison est une
aventure sans lendemain une simple
relation physique
moi j'étais le numéro de elsfun c'était
le numéro 1 pour marcels je sais que
c'est comme ça et j'accepte elle
explique effectivement que elle a besoin
d'être rassuré qu'elle a pas une autre
estime d'elle-même et que quand un homme
accepte de la prendre dans son lit il
est déjà contente comme ça et elle
scrutement va aller plus loin
lorsque les inspecteurs lui demandent
qui selon elle a tué la parachutiste sa
réponse va s'avérer très étonnante bon
presque comme une criminolo aux
enquêteurs et donc elle arrive à faire
ce raisonnement aussi
que dans cette histoire au fond il n'y a
que trois suspects possibles Yann de
Wild qui est l'époux trahit
Marcel qui est l'amant qui en a
peut-être marre de pas être choisi en
numéro 1 et qu'elle reste quand même
avec son mari et puis elle aussi
chose étrange elle scottomans s'inclut
elle-même dans la liste des suspects
mais très vite elle sera vise en
ajoutant immédiatement
elle l'a pas fait donc ce sont les deux
autres soit c'est le mari soit c'est
Martin Solange
c'est pas moi
mauvaise idée les enquêteurs ne le
savent pas encore mais lors de son
audition else clottomans Laura apporté
la réponse à l'énigme l'un des trois
suspects et bien la sasa
nous sommes le 19 décembre 2006 un mois
après le drame
elle scottomans vient d'être admise à
l'hôpital d'as dans la banlieue de
Bruxelles
[Musique]
la jeune femme a tenté de mettre fin à
ses jours
la mer de elsclottomans la découvre dans
sa chambre semi-comateux sur son lit
inanimé elle a visiblement fait une
tentative de suicide on retrouve des
plaquettes de médicaments c'est pas très
bien ce que c'est mais elle a fait une
tentative de suicide la mère qui est
infirmière c'est tout de suite que c'est
très grave elle l'emmène à l'hôpital à
as et là
et bien on lui fait un pompage de
l'estomac
elle est hors de danger une fois
réveillé est-ce que Mans va expliquer la
raison de son geste
elle confie que la veille dans la soirée
son amant Marcel Summers lui a annoncé
qu'il souhaitait mettre un terme à leur
relation
Marcel Summers lui dit qu'il n'a plus le
goût à la vie qu'il a perdu sa raison de
vivre et que il va arrêter le
parachutisme et que la relation avec
elle scottomane ce n'est pas saine et
que ça ça ne peut pas continuer ainsi il
est plus intéressé en elle
et pour elle
le saumonde tombe au beau milieu de la
nuit anéanti par cette nouvelle la jeune
femme avale des médicaments
puis elle écrit plusieurs mots d'adieu
qu'elle va laisser bien en évidence
en ce moment-là on trouve plusieurs
lettres d'adieu adressés à ses proches
et à ses amis
[Musique]
et une lettre humaine à Sommers
dans ce courrier adressé à Marcel
Sommers même si elle continue de nier le
sabotage la jeune femme fait une
confession inattendue dans cette lettre
elle avoue clairement que c'est elle qui
a envoyé la lettre anonyme à elle se
vanderen en 2005
outre les menaces proférées par els clos
de Mans ce sont les circonstances dans
lesquelles le courrier était envoyé qui
intrigue les enquêteurs
alors est-ce que Thomas avait pris
toutes les précautions pour envoyer
cette lettre c'est une lettre
tapée à la machine cette lettre anonyme
elle scottomans avait fait en sorte de
la poster en dehors de sa région elle
avait pris soin de de coller le timbre
avec de l'eau du robinet elle avait
manipuler cette enveloppe avec des gants
chirurgicaux tout comportement qui
n'apparaît pas aux policiers comme étant
celui d'un petit blagueur mais bien
comme celui d'un criminel
ce jour-là les enquêteurs la justice
c'est une découverte
déterminante dans toute l'affaire donc
là on trouve la preuve écrite
qu'elle est un le corbeau des lettres
et deuxièmement qu'elle a voulu faire
sauter
la relation de la victime avec son amant
pour les enquêteurs ces éléments
apportent tout à coup un nouvel
éclairage à l'affaire contrairement à ce
qu'elle a toujours prétendu elle sclote
serait très amoureuse de Marcel Sommer
et elle n'aurait plus supporter d'être
relégué au second plan
c'est la preuve qu'elle était qu'elle
était extrêmement jalouse de Hells
wonderwan
que cette jalousie bien évidemment
constitue un motif suffisant pour
éventuellement en arriver au meurtre
et pour la première fois on a une
suspecte solide elle est automatique
[Musique]
peu à peu les policiers commencent
taélaborer un scénario pour eux tous
s'est déroulé la fameuse nuit où elle
scrotomans a été relégué sur le canapé
tandis que S vanderen et Marcel faisait
l'amour dans la pièce à côté
au milieu de la nuit est-ce que Mons ce
serait levé et aurait saboté le
parachute avant de se recoucher
lors de leur saut suivant else
claudemans aurait agi comme si Dorian
était
à un détail près
[Musique]
souvenez-vous lors de la chute fatale la
jeune femme avait raté sa sortie
les policiers en sont persuadés ce
retard ne doit rien au hasard est-ce que
demande aurait volontairement sauté
après les autres
son but tenter d'apercevoir le lieu où
l'extracteur allait tomber
les policiers disent toujours que
exclutman a fait ça exprès qu'elle n'a
pas
essayé de faire la formation avec les
trois autres justement pour pouvoir
suivre l'extracteur
mince savait en effet qu'une fois
retrouvé les analyses de ce petit
parachute confirmerait la piste du
sabotage
et dans son esprit le mari trompé Yann
de Wilde serait immédiatement mis en
cause et cela pour une raison simple il
avait très facilement accès au parachute
de sa femme car elle le rangèrent
régulièrement à leur domicile il pouvait
donc facilement sectionner une sangle
si on retrouve
le petit parachute
ça va mettre en fait le mari en
difficulté
et puis ils ont fait la conclusion c'est
madame claudemas qui a trouvé justement
donc parachute pour en fait mettre la
faute sur le dos de Monsieur donc de le
mari
les enquêteurs se sont fait une
conviction mais il ne dispose toujours
d'aucune preuve pire encore leur
acharnement va vite se retourner contre
eux
nous sommes le 17 janvier 2016 soit deux
mois après le meurtre
également persuadé de sa culpabilité le
juge décide de placer else clottomans en
détention provisoire à la prison
d'asselt
[Musique]
mais à l'approche du procès peu à peu un
doute commence à apparaître dans
l'opinion
atro vouloir accuser else clôtdement les
policiers ont-ils vraiment exploré
toutes les pistes
comment être sûr qu'ils ne sont pas
passés à côté du véritable assassin
97% de l'instruction qui a été fait sur
hansclottomans justement pour pouvoir
prouver qu'elle squattement a commis le
meurtre et seulement trois pourcents qui
a été faites de l'instruction pour
trouver un autre personne qui a
peut-être commis le meurtre
pour être certain qu'ils ne font pas
fausse route les policiers décident
alors d'employer les grands moyens
le 8 février 2007 les enquêteurs
décident de faire passer aux trois
principaux suspects le test du
polygraphe l'autre nom que l'on donne au
détecteur de mensonges
on installe
Yann Deville dans une pièce où il va
être interrogé bon il a déjà été
interrogé par les policiers mais là le
test est un petit peu spécial on va lui
installer des électrodes sur le corps au
niveau du cœur
et on va lui poser toute une série de
questions très précise sur un ton très
neutre
avez-vous saboter le parachute d'Els
wonderen
non
[Musique]
connaissez-vous la personne qui a saboté
le parachute Belz Vando run
non
saviez-vous qu'elles se vante de Run
avait une relation avec Marcel Sommers
non
il est très stressé il a peur que ça
joue en sa défaveur il a tout à perdre
dans ce test mais le passe quand même il
répond chaque fois non
il passe ce test avec succès
selon le détecteur de mensonge Yann de
Wild n'aurait donc pas tué son épouse
reste désormais deux suspects Marcel
Sommers et else claudeman eux aussi vont
devoir passer cette épreuve
deux jours plus tard c'est à Marcel
Sommers d'être soumis au test
[Musique]
on les place des capteurs sur sur tout
le corps il est effectivement stressé à
lui aussi on lui pose les mêmes
questions que Yann de Wind ou à peu près
et à aucune des questions qui lui sont
posées on ne détecte la moindre
variation la moindre manifestation
excessive d'émotion emballement de
pulsion cardiaque par exemple donc il
était établi au terme de ce test que
Marcel Summers lui non plus n'a pas
menti au cours de ce test en tout cas
pour les policiers qui sont quand même
fait un petit peu taper dessus depuis
quelques semaines par par la presse
belge c'était c'est une revanche une
revanche c'est d'ailleurs en fait ça
confirme que le travail qui est mené
depuis le début autour de elle
scottomans doit continuer pour les
inspecteurs c'est une petite victoire
elle scottomans demeure la seule
suspecte potentielle
et il lui propose de passer le test du
polygraphe mais alors grande surprise
elle refuse
je donne conseil depuis le début à un
slottement de ne pas se soumettre au
polygraphe
pour la simple raison que un stattement
prenait des médicaments quand tu es
entré en prison il les prend toujours et
ce sont des médicaments
contre la dépression nerveuse dont elle
souffre son des médicaments qui
influencent ou qui peuvent influencer
les résultats d'un polygraphe donc il
n'a aucune raison de se soumettre aux
politiques de détecteurs
certains systèmes très très délicat il y
a beaucoup de fautes et j'ai
l'impression que le policier vont cet
usage donc de ce détecteur de mensonges
quand ils n'ont pas d'autres éléments le
refus d'elslottomans de participer à ce
test et les résultats qui innocentrent
les deux autres suspects pourrait
immédiatement accuser la jeune femme
seulement il y a un problème pour la
justice belge le détecteur de mensonges
jugé peu fiable n'a pas de valeur devant
un tribunal
à l'approche du procès les policiers
n'ont donc rien d'autre que leur
présomption
seront-elles suffisantes pour convaincre
les jurés
vendredi 24 septembre 2010 c'est le
procès de l'année qui débute à la cour
d'assises du Limbourg
la salle est comble les médias et le
public ont pris d'assaut le tribunal
c'est l'amour le sexe le parachutisme
tout ça ça fait un cocktail assez
spécial je pense il y a une tension
incroyable
c'est pas aussi de façon normale c'est
pas calme c'est extrêmement énervé tout
le monde est présent
les journalistes sont là me posent des
questions sans fin
dans le box des accusés
elslottements la jeune femme a été
libérée de prison il y a près d'un an et
demi dans l'attente de son procès
problème c'est qu'elle m'a donné une
très très mauvaise image dès le premier
jour dès l'ouverture du procès elle
apparaît très fatiguée elle est mal
habillée malfagoté son regard est vite
elle ne regarde que devant elle elle ne
prête pas attention
au jurer elle elle n'est pas entretenue
elle a pris des médicaments elle est
bouffis les Groggies elle répond en
Nananan aux questions de la Cour
d'Assise elle slotomons fait mauvaise
impression et lorsque la cour fait
diffusée la vidéo enregistrée en plein
saut par la victime chacun va avoir le
sentiment que l'accusé est impliqué dans
un crime particulièrement cruel
c'est la mort en direct c'est la c'est
réellement ce qui s'est passé ce n'est
pas une reconstitution c'est vraiment
S22 a filmé sa mort sur le banc des juré
c'est la concernation de certains
beaucoup d'émotions
face à ces images le mari de la victime
Yann de Wild qui assiste au procès avec
son fils et sa fille décide de quitter
la salle
la famille de la victime ses deux ans
les deux enfants dès le 22 le père en
pleurs ils vont tous les trois sortir et
quels sont les images qui pour eux sont
insupportables
dans les jours qui suivent les témoins
se succèdent à la barre et certains
récits particulièrement à charge vont
retenir l'attention de la cour
il y a d'abord Yann de Wild le mari de
la victime il revient sur les obsèques
de son épouse et il raconte que ce
jour-là l'accusé a fait preuve d'un
comportement pour le moins choquant
elle serait automatique avait prévu de
lire une lettre mais il y a de l'huile
n'était pas d'accord il lui avait
demandé
que contient cette lettre elle lui avait
dit c'est une surprise finalement il a
quand même réussi à lire ce qu'il y
avait dans cette lettre il y avait
énormément de Black salace
faire une allusion très déplacée sur la
plaque d'immatriculation de Vendôme avec
les lettres sa U qui qui veut dire en
allemand [__] [__] donc là
finalement elle ne lit rien du tout elle
n'apprend pas la parole mais en 2000
explique au procès que
c'était pour lui totalement inacceptable
c'est ensuite autour de Marcel Sommers
flamant lui aussi va raconter une
anecdote troublante à propos
delsclottomans
le lendemain ou le surlendemain du drame
baps avait débarqué dans son appartement
qu'elle s'était déshabillée jeté sur lui
qu'elle avait essayé d'avoir des
relations sexuelles avec lui alors que
lui était complètement à plat il
réalisait à peine ce qui s'était passé
et que et que donc elle a un
comportement franchement déplacé
ma seule explique que c'était pas le
comportement de quelqu'un qui qui
ont perdu une bonne copine
c'est le comportement de quelqu'un qui
qui
fait sa victoire
face à ses accusations les avocats de la
jeune femme ont bien du mal à convaincre
d'autant que les témoignages des experts
psychiatres vont alors tour brosser
d'elle un portrait accablant
de la personnalité qui c'est quelqu'un
qui manque d'empathie qui a du mal à
comprendre les sentiments des autres qui
traitent vers elle
[Musique]
après 18 jours de procès le jury
s'apprête à se retirer pour délibérer
mais depuis le box des accusés elle
scrutement va s'adresser une dernière
fois au juré
la voix tremble elle n'est pas à son
aise du tout
et elle affirme quand tout honnêteté
c'est ce qu'elle dit depuis 4 ans elle
vit un enfer et voilà
je suis pas coupable
je peux rien dire d'autre je l'ai pas
fait on m'a toujours cherché
c'est pas moi
la foule piétine devant les portes du
palais
dans quelques minutes le verdict va être
rendu
la place manque dans la salle d'audience
il y a du monde partout le Palais de
Justice
a fait ouvert
une pièce avec un écran géant il y a
plus de 500 personnes dans cette salle
il y a du monde dehors il y a du monde
dans les cafés le public fait la queue
depuis le matin pour être sûr de pas
rater
rater le verdict on a vraiment
l'impression qu'on est plus au théâtre
que dans une salle d'audience d'un
palais de justice
l'attention est vraiment à son maximum
on se dit qu'est-ce qui va se passer
va-t-elle être jugé coupable ou pas
il est 14h25 c'est l'heure de vérité
dans un silence pesant le verdict est
annoncé par le président du tribunal
elle verse quelques larmes sa mère et
son frère eux sont en sanglots
les jurés ne bougent pas
la sentence est lourde et dans ce procès
où l'épreuve matérielle sont
inexistantes
l'attitude de la prévenue semble avoir
joué contre elle de fait
du côté de la famille de la victime en
particulier du mari c'est un peu la joie
c'est peut-être pas le mot mais c'est le
soulagement c'est le soulagement
l'enquête est terminée on tient une
coupable visiblement les faits sont
établis pour la justice donc c'est un
peu la fin
entre guillemets du Calvaire après tout
le mystère quand on est la mort de la
mort de Alzheimer
selon le droit pénal belge elslottomans
pourra faire une demande de remise en
liberté lorsqu'elle aura purgé un tiers
de sa peine
en 2019 elle pourra donc être libérée
seulement il y a une condition à cela
elle devra depuis sa prison avouer le
meurtre pour lequel elle a été condamnée
[Musique]